[Music]
from the beat of drums to horns
a steady blast from trucks parked near
parliament the trucker protest reached
its final destination with anger toward
reporters boiling
you should be embarrassed to be a
journalist
that convoy of trucks and thousands of
protesters on foot here at parliament
hill with one message no we're looking
for freedom
we're looking for freedom that's the
only thing every single thing that the
that our governments have done
it just keeps on getting worse against
lockdowns and mandatory vaccinations in
workplaces i cannot tolerate to see any
longer because
we're we're not we're not living like we
should be against government-opposed
lockdowns and mandatory covenanting
vaccinations in workplaces these adverse
reactions are not as rare as the media
would like to have us believe they're
not they don't seem to be working
they're failing they're ineffective most
downtown ottawa businesses remain closed
for the protest police warned about the
risk of violence i think it's horrible i
think what they stand for is wrong not
backed by science and shouldn't be in
our city this man one of a few counter
protesters supporting vaccines shown in
recent data by canada's top doctors to
be overwhelmingly safe and prevent
covert related death i mean i got my
jacket ripped
i've been called racial and homophobic
slurs
all day most of the crowd were upbeat
everybody needs a hug there was a pop-up
arm wrestling match yet some were
wrapped in donald trump flags supporting
the former u.s president i want to see
trump back in 2024
of course
he's the best but mostly we are standing
for our children and of and for our
grandchildren
to have masks because children can
breathe god given fresh air and they say
they're not a fringe minority claiming
more canadians share their view than
people think you gotta tell
the people
the truth charles shea global news
ottawa